right-hander you darvish on the mound
for the chicago cubs he would love to
pick up where kyle hendricks left off
last night
that'll bring up a key free agent
signing in justin smoke
justin smoke in the pits a swinging a
drive
into center and the base set and the
inning continues for the crew
abaciel garcia is the batter now
here at second smoking first another 2-2
got him corbin burns getting another
opportunity in the rotation he came
one two to brian waves and misses and
there's a strikeout for burns on the
slider and that's his wipeout push
kyle schwaber playing in left field
today is the batter now
and now schwarber takes strike three
call the fastball got him looking that's
a great pitch right there
you know it had a little cut action and
that's what he does there's wilson
contreras
0-2 up and in at 98 that time
and why i i don't necessarily like that
is because he doesn't exhibit great
control and the last thing you want to
do
o2 is hit somebody a two-two on the way
line drive toward left they sit rizzo to
third he's gonna try to score here comes
the throw by gamal to the plate
it's offline rizzo slides in and scores
going to third on the play as baez run
scoring single wilson
contreras cubs lead one to nothing from
the milwaukee dugout chris hook
is a second year pitching coach they
send a trainer out there too just but he
knows maybe
maybe it's his right nostril
that is being problematic here but he
threw one pitch he says let's go ahead
and play
and the pitch a swing and a bouncer
auto in the inning it will ben he's
playing left field today
one two on the ground towards the
shortstop gloved by baez and they've got
kane in a rundown
brian toss back kipnis
[Applause]
baez again gamel is stuck
at second base now and the cubs will not
get a single out on that play
and that is very surprising considering
the defensive prowess on that infield
so they're doing everything right the
brewers right kane stays in the rundown
gamel gets a second but watch when kane
goes back down
he starts point see a point point point
he
recognizes that nobody's at first base
now for me
that's got to be carrottini and rizzo
both can't be standing at home
you don't need two guys at home right
there and back to the top
and eric sogart garbage deals again and
sogard
sends one into shallow center it's gonna
drop for a base hit
lorenzo kane is in and a soft single for
sogard ties this game one-two picture on
the way to call
struck him out swinging beautiful
breaking ball on the outside corner
contreras chirping again during that
last break
got a little bit heated as some cubs
players were outside of the dugout
screaming to the other side christian
yelich at one point jumped the dug out
and
started to just amble his way towards
the field i think this is going to be
part of this season i mean
both dugouts can hear each other and
you know um players can hear everything
and so it's you know there's there's
talking that goes on in the game
you never hear it with all the fans here
and right it's just it's part of the
game
it's competitiveness that's all it is so
the first two men are on and ben gamel
will be the batter chance to take the
lead for the brewers and much more the
pitch
and a line shot towards right field that
is headed towards the gap it's going to
go all the way to the wall
two runs are going to score for the
brewers gamel is on his way to second
not stopping there here's the throw to
third
naughty time then camel with a two-run
triple i mean this pitch just up in the
zone right here
gamble just absolutely crushes this and
this is how you answer right there's
some banter going on
back and forth a couple base hits here
next thing you know they put two runs on
the board
single on a strikeout so far today for
justin
smoked winning on a 2-0 pitch there it
is and it's hit
in the air and in the right and it is
going to be
out of here and the brewers have one
more justin smoke connects
and rudely greets dwayne underwood in
his first inning of the season
four to one brewers on top al schwarber
at the plate
kyle schwarber drills one way
way back that one is a no doubter this
is a little cutter and
absolutely demolishes it it's out over
the plate
obviously if you're gonna go out over
the plate you can't be
and the pitch to yell at hit in the air
in the center
warning track get up get out of here and
gone
christian yelled oh this is just a
four-seamer that
is ready for takeoff and he absolutely
gets a hold of that
two gone cubs are down to their last
chance
punches it on the ground to first smoke
is there and the milwaukee brewers
even up this opening weekend series at a
game of peace
with an 8-3 saturday win